le cyclomoteur deux pédales moins de 50
centimètres cubes 45 km heure maximum du
bruit l'odeur caractéristique du pot
d'échappement son fameux guide ont pas
de doute il s'agit bien du peugeot 103
apparu il ya cinquante ans à la fin de
l'année 1971 symbole d'une époque celle
des années 70 80 quand ce cyclomoteur
faisait le bonheur des jeunes
une mob une meule une bécane appelez le
comme vous voulez à la sortie des lycées
les salles de concert le peugeot 103
encombre des trottoirs les ados veulent
tous savoir leur cyclomoteur objet de
liberté dis-moi sylvain à toi aussi tu
as un cyclomoteur l'auteur d'occasion
d'occasion et qui est ce qu'il a payé
j'ai travaillé
mais à moi c'est pas suffisant quand
même pour un cyclo même d'occasion gelé
payer 300 francs si tu aimes pas très
cher et les parents
certains n'ont pas le choix et sont
traînés par leurs enfants dans les
boutiques spécialisées
vous venez vous renseigner à propos d'un
cyclomoteur pour votre fils me
renseigner acheter parce que je connais
déjà la marque alors j'ai acheté déjà
pour mon grand lemps maintenant c'est
pour le deuxième il a essayé avec des
camarades et comme ça lui a plu alors
maintenant je sens qu'il est
increvable bon marché accessible dès 14
ans et sans permis le peugeot 103 n'est
pas le seul modèle de la gamme voici le
peugeot 103 sport sorti en 1979 c'est un
style qui va vous donner envie de faire
du cross mais à vos risques et périls
car l'engin n'est pas vraiment conçu
pour cet usage mais ce qui est beaucoup
plus sérieuses et le guide au d'un seul
tenant qui équipe le sens troyes sport
ce qui écarte enfin la dangereuse
tentation de rapprocher les deux
branches de ce guidon comme on peut le
faire sur de nombreux modèles
ou encore le peugeot 103 copper sorti en
1982 un modèle plus moderne plus
puissant que le 103 traditionnel un
engin à vocation urbaine évidente à mi
chemin entre le scooter et le
cyclomoteur traditionnelle dans les
années 80 le peugeot 103 continue
d'avoir la cote il reste un symbole
d'évasion et d'émancipation pour les
ados c'est une nécessité c'est à dire
que nécessité mais son influence des
amis aussi puisque tout le monde avait
une mobylette l'attaquant vélo j'avais
15 ans j'étais derrière à pédaler
à partir des années 90 le taux jousson 3
devient ringard les jeunes le délai de
profit du scooter plus moderne est à la
mode le dernier exemplaire français est
sorti d'usiné en 2006
[Musique]